how to get people to wake up
i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
dieter and dieter is a long term long
time loyal
youtube fan so i love answering his
questions and he was he always makes me
think
so this is a great one he wrote in to
say is there an easy way to lose or
limiting personal beliefs let me explain
i was aware at the age 24 that i have
something more
at that time i couldn't label that
something but i still push forward
when i was 30 i had a tough time in my
life it was a time where i had
to choose to chase my dream or be
unhappy all my life and he chose to
chase his dream and in the past two
years
i'd achieved more than i've ever
achieved in my life personally mentally
spiritually physically
i like to help people shake them and
wake them but sometimes i don't know how
to help them
i woke up because of a tough situation i
don't
like that for people with potential do
you know an easy way to wake up
this is a great question and something
that i honestly still
struggle with because i love helping
entrepreneurs and i want to see you get
the best you can out of your life and
out of your business
and it's great i love the noble cause
that you're doing and you're doing
something important and greater than
yourself
so how to actually get it done first
what i've come to discover and
understand is that good is the enemy of
great
okay if your life sucks if your business
sucks if you're really unhappy
it's easy to want to make a change you
want to make a change because your life
sucks
so i will do anything to get out of this
hole because
i am not happy so you're going to find a
way to make a change
and you're you're more receptive to
making bigger changes
if your life is good it's okay you know
maybe you hate your job but you like
your weekend life and
you have a family and you're happy with
that and your life is just good and okay
you're less willing to want to make a
change
because it's good because change is
painful
right if you're in a painful spot you'll
take the pain
because that's nothing compared to the
crappy life you're living now
but if your life is good making a change
is pain and
i don't want to do that so good is the
enemy of great
and so sometimes people need that really
painful point like you did in your life
to realize how you can change and grow
and we may have to go through that
to get to where we need to go the second
way i found to be really helpful is just
be an example because
ramming something down somebody's throat
that that doesn't work
tell them you need to do this you need
to do it's not going to work right
imagine if somebody's giving that to you
you're not going to be receptive to it a
great way i found is to just
be an example if you're living a happy
life now
you know you love what you do you have
energy you're following your passion
you're a happy person you will attract
people to you
right people like being around happy
positive
energetic people people don't like
hanging around the guys who are always
down on life
and telling you how everything's going
to fail right the little man nobody
likes hanging around the little man
so be the happy energetic person and you
will attract people to you
who will want to know your secret and
who want to live like you
you know i share the stuff that i do
right i like to go snowboarding like to
go salsa dancing
and it's inspired other people to do
those things too
and to take action on those personal
interests but also
on the business advice that i give right
when i'm talking it's positive it's
upbeat it's energetic
i'm not coming on saying yeah i gotta go
salsa dancing
whatever that's not gonna inspire
anything
so you have to be positive upbeat and
you are like if you're happy with your
life right now you will attract other
people
the third thing i found is
help people see
the greater picture help people believe
in themselves more
that's what this is where this comes
from right belief
a lot of people have such limiting
beliefs
and they see greatness in other people
but they don't see it in themselves they
don't see how they could do something
great but they see it in other people
so just help people see the greatness
inside of them and what they could
become
i have a friend of mine bailey who is an
entrepreneur has a successful company
and now he's looking to she's got to do
something else with her life she's
looking to get to the next step and
and she's changing and evolving she
doesn't know what it looks like she
doesn't know what she's going to do
so she's experimenting with a lot of
different things like a lot of us can
relate to that where you're
you've done something for a certain
amount of time and then you start
getting bored
and you don't know what to do next and
she's taking the courage to go out and
just try a whole bunch of different
stuff and i said bailey you got to
document
this you got to put these on videos you
got to put it on youtube
you got to talk about it because your
journey
will inspire millions of people
with her ability to connect with people
and her courage to take this step where
most people
they wouldn't do it because she has a
good life she's going for great
most people wouldn't take that step you
will inspire millions of people
and she doesn't she didn't believe it
right she's like ah nobody's gonna watch
he sings nobody cares my stuff is crap
but we all think what we make
videos especially are just crap at the
start
and she put up a video and somebody
commented on it
and said i forget what the comment was
like go bailey or you're an inspiration
or something like that and she's
because of that one comment now spending
more time
on her videos right she's actually
preparing instead of just sitting down
and talking about whatever comes to her
mind she's actually preparing for it
and the videos are gonna get better and
it's like bailey
you will inspire millions of people this
is gonna happen
and it's gonna come from people watching
your videos so you have to make them
better
right and as the message gets repeated
and she starts to see progress and
momentum she starts to believe it more
where she never would have thought that
she would help so many people but i see
a clear picture for her and she's going
to get there
and so believing in people and showing
them
how they could be much greater
and helping them believe in themselves
more just having one person
who believes in you can make the
difference but if you're surrounded by
people who just
pound on you and put you back in place
and tell you how things aren't going to
work you know the little man
just having one person say
i believe in you that can make the
difference
and so you could be that person to sum
it all up though
you have to remember that it's their
life
right it's their life and no matter how
badly you want it for them
they still have to live their life right
it's still
on them you could be the greatest
motivator
the greatest inspiration the greatest
you know shining a positive light on
people but it's still
at the end of the day up to them to
change their life
and forcing them isn't going to work all
you can do is plant seeds
you plant seeds you plant ideas and you
try to water them and try to grow them
and some people react
really quickly and will scoop up
everything you're saying and take
immediate action
and for some people it may take years
may take years for them to come back so
you know what what that dieter guy
said it's starting to make sense
so don't get frustrated i know you want
to help everybody
really quickly i see it too i help
entrepreneurs some people pick it up and
scoop it and they're running others are
are just floundering around like i gave
you the end what i gave you the answer
what are you doing go
i told you what to do it's gonna work
and they
just some people have to go at their own
pace
and that's okay but i love what you're
doing
i love that you're trying to help people
and um
and i'm inspired by your success story
as well so believe
everybody watching thumbs up below if
you liked it let me know what you think
leave a comment ask me a question below
and if you want to see more videos like
this click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much and i'll see you soon